hello everyone and welcome to one of the
more enjoyable chess games uh you might
run into it's a game from 1956 or so
they say between paul carys and the
gentleman known only as the friedrich or
friedrich um and that we don't have any
other um uh
information about this gentleman so
there's the photo of the hoodie guy and
why i'm wearing a hoodie most of you
guys know this but uh
it's always nice to to remember
why we do things and i remember seeing
this game when i first started uh
learning about chess it's actually
it's actually also present in a book my
grandfather gave me uh by boris lavikov
i mentioned the book
uh when we made a video on on boris
lavkov after his death
so it's the theory of openings and it
features a lot of cool games and this is
uh
one of them that i've failed to show so
far uh but it's super enjoyable as it's
only 10 moves now it's um sometimes the
game is uh being seen as uh derived from
the from the scotch game sometimes that
we have some different openings
sometimes we have an early g6 and then
we transpose into sort of a sort of a
scotch game uh but it doesn't matter as
the idea is what uh what really matters
so let's dive straight into it and then
i have a very very important
announcement this is why i chose a very
short game for today as we well there
are a lot of very strong tournaments
starting now the third leg of the grand
prix and the meltwater champions chess
store and we're gonna have a lot of uh
longer games i imagine so that's why uh
let's check out a nice short one that
you can always use to crush your friends
and enemies uh so here uh keras opens
with e4 we have e5 and now knight to f3
we have knight to c6 and d4 now the
squad game is on the board like i said
you could you can find this game in the
database uh or rather different
databases um uh with with a different
move order but let's stick to this one e
captures on the four knight captures and
now comes the weird move for uh from
black usually you're just going to play
knight to f6 here sometimes maybe you
even play bishop to c5 or bishop to b
for check this has all been played but
here black plays knight g to e7 and
already this goes against uh some
well-known and established opening
principles where you wanna castle as
soon as possible and to develop your
pieces um uh well to optimal squares to
control as much uh uh
space as possible so here you can see
that black will require three more moves
to castle you're you're going to have to
move the knight in you're going to have
to develop the bishop and then you're
going to castle or you're going to have
to play g6 bishop to g7 and then castle
which is three moves instead if you play
knight to f6 then you can just develop
the bishop castle the king and that's it
so here how do we take advantage of this
knight to c3 and now black sticks to his
plan and he plays g6 which is not
possible black is already completely
lost in this game but of course black
doesn't know this and well it's very
interesting how do you exploit this
weakness even pause the video and try to
figure out a winning move for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding this
incredible pin and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is bishop
to g5 this is the move that wins the
game for white uh to give you uh an idea
why uh well how is uh how is black
defending uh our main threat is to play
knights to d5 uh threatening uh uh just
check made in one with knight to f6
check and black doesn't really have all
that much to uh do about this if you
play knight captures on d4 let's say
queen captures on d4 uh the rook is
hanging we're going to move the rook now
comes knight d5 again we have the same
thread knife knight to f6 is the threat
of checkmate and if you play bishop to
g7 uh to give your king an escape square
attack the white queen we're just gonna
play e5 and still how are you now
defending the knight on e7 we're just
gonna pick it up and that's it so not
not a lot of fun for black so instead
after bishop to g5 we have bishop to g7
black says all right you continue with
your plan i'm just gonna win a piece
here as the both of my pieces are
attacking your knight now but kara says
nope uh that's just um
not happening i'm playing knight to d5
and now you can resign
but black
of course doesn't resign
and
continues with bishop captures on d4 but
just to show you what happens if you
play something like castles of course we
just remove the defender of the e7
knight with knight captures on c6 you
can't capture with the knight because
the queen hangs so after b captures or d
captures we just pick up the knight here
and that's it knight captures an e7
check we're up a piece completely
winning so instead after knight to d5 we
have bishop captures on d4 and now comes
the move that uh
our good friend friedrich probably
missed and that is queen captures on the
e4 so kira just gives up the queen uh as
black is getting checkmated there's
nothing for black to do here uh
the rook is hanging so rook captures and
h8 will also be dead the queen captures
rook and he will also be deadly so black
accepted the queen but now of course
comes knight to f6 check only move for
black king f8 and bishop to h6 checkmate
so like i said this is only 10 moves
we've
explored some lines so it might seem a
little bit longer but just to give you a
very quick overview so e4 e5 knight to
f3 knight c6 let's say we go into this
line with a scotch captures captures and
not knight g to e7 so once when you play
the scotch and someone plays this weird
move against you you should know that
you are very very close uh to winning
this game and you're just gonna continue
naturally developing developing your
pieces your opponent will probably play
g6 because why else would he play knight
g to e7 and now you play bishop to g5
the move you've all found during the
pause the video moment and your opponent
can just resign bishop g7 you sacrifice
the queen not a problem bishop captures
queen captures knight captures and of
course it's made into knight f6 jerk
king here and bishop to h6 checkmate so
really uh spectacular miniature
i was very happy when i saw this for the
first time so for those of you who are
seeing it for the first time i imagine
you are very happy as well
so that's uh the game uh but now
regarding the announcement uh on the
20th of march so yeah that's in two days
time
uh i believe it's uh 2 p.m unless
something changes i will inform you uh i
will be playing a simultaneous
exhibition against judith polgar uh
along uh some other streamers uh not uh
well we're not gonna be playing against
her ourselves we're gonna play against
her uh using our entire community so i
will be live streaming the event judit
will be playing on an actual physical
board uh and
well uh she will make a move we will
receive the move on our uh application
that we're going to be using for the
effort game for the square of boards uh
and then of course we'll make our move
and then the move will be uh played in
dubai where she's uh holding the
simultaneous exhibition so uh like
everyone else i will be live streaming
this event you guys are welcome to join
in you guys are welcome to suggest moves
and of course uh uh i would very much
enjoy it if you guys did not use um uh
you know a computer assistant so just
enjoy the positions you know give your
own thought about the position uh and i
will uh you know just go through your
through your uh ideas and then we're
gonna uh play a movie if i uh if i
realize that something you know weird is
happening then uh of course uh i'm not
gonna play that move or i might even
play a silly move just uh you know keep
the keep the game going because uh
there's no really way for me to
uh to
uh
well uh know if if uh anyone suggesting
a move is is doing it uh of their own
accord or is it
uh something else but uh i i will be
having a pretty good idea so mostly
let's try let's try to keep it a good
game let's uh have a lot of fun and
let's uh you know not try
uh and and to do anything um no one
would uh would want to do uh so yeah uh
that's uh that's the game and the
announcement i hope you guys enjoyed
that hope to see as many of you as as
possible on
on the live stream on sunday uh i would
like to
thank davao central for uh wishing uh
meadow a happy birthday and i would like
to thank john austin for wishing meadow
abilities happy birthday and i would
like to thank joel dopplet uh ellen
folsom and joe guzman for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon i'm continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
crush as many as people as you can with
this
i hope it goes well for you
see you soon